here we are with Zach the sound lad we
are making our first official okay we've
re-imagined the lore videos and we are
honoring Zach today
the Mad genius behind the sound bite I'm
honored thank you very much I appreciate
it thank you and Joker brain as well
thank you thank you uh you've been with
us for what five over five years going
on five years going on five years
Zach came to us a sweet young lad
actually you were in college at the time
I was going to uh Community College
studying to become an attorney and um
an attorney yeah well I don't know what
the [__] happened there but um wow
um lodged a bullet potentially yeah you
know it's something the parents want you
to do Jewish grandparents parents you
have to get the profession
so you're in school and then you you
reached out to us we were saying we need
a sound guy because our levels are crazy
and just as we were talking about that
we get an email from sweet young Zack
who says he's a musician
and I guess that we're like it kind of
kind of works
so he had Dan Reach Out I said Dan meet
him at Starbucks or something make sure
he's not a weirdo
I met him at the coffee being down the
street from the old office how was that
meeting for you Dan when you first met
him it was good we clicked immediately
Zach's chill I felt you know immediately
got a good vibe from him and knew it
would be a good fit there it is
sweetheart so he Dan and Dorsey says
okay let's bring him in uh you were
working freelance for us
and then you're like I I don't how did
it happen where you dropped out of
college don't blame me no I don't have
that on me do not blame him although it
worked out I mean you've been physically
employed right it was the best thing I'm
not regretting it the best thing I ever
did um
so I was going to LMU for like
not even a full semester transferring
from Community College and I was just
like what the [__] am I doing here and
I'm like this is not the path for me and
you and Ela are like well do you want to
come work full time like hell yeah Dan
was our only full-time employee at that
point I think on the podcast I don't
remember it's been so damn long ago yeah
but um yeah it's it's changed my life
and um
I really have well
I have a lot of a lot of thanks to you
was my next sentence you know uh Zach
brings a special
we're both fans of of Howard Stern and
on there the king of sound bites Fred
Norris and uh I think we were trying to
emulate that and over the years the
whole sound bite setup has really
transformed and mutated and leveled up
yeah a lot over the years oh yeah
um you're like
take this and and run with it and like
do your thing and I'm like okay I have
all this knowledge of Fred all these
years of listening
let's see what the kid's made of
and so I owe it all to you
thank you again you can say that you can
say that more throughout this
conversation no uh well listen we got we
have an hour and a half of footage wow
so this is the deep deep lore of Zach
The Sound Lab I hope you guys enjoy
we're gonna do one of these for each
crew member and they all just sure
deserve it but this is going to be such
a fun watch I'm gonna definitely watch
this whole thing hell yeah and uh relive
the pleasures and the joys I love you I
love you
you're my boy my Golden Boy you always
have my back
[Music]
all right so to start it off I thought
we'd double react to your first
appearance ever wonderful do you
remember what it was I think it had
something to do with wiping wiping okay
okay at first I was backing you up on
something okay okay let's see Zack I
just heard our sound guy he's our sound
intern he's helping us out with sound he
told me today that in his house they
don't even have toilet paper they go
pure wet wipe which is still true which
I have never seen I've never seen that
and frankly I find it a little strange
because I would never I would never
recommend to start what
because that's just asking for trouble I
recommend to Zach and to all anyone else
out there you have to take a hybrid
approach because you want to start try
and what so Zach welcome aboard
pretty strange Zach do you wipe from the
front or the back can you talk into the
mic I I do the uh you decline method
at first I was doing things I started
working here I tried it out and I happen
to really like it wait are you [__]
kidding me it's just a big moment Zach
is admitting to wiping scooping if you
would from you go under the ball sack
yes like me you have to you cup your
balls in dick that's it and you scoop
away yep towards the balls yep that's
that's exactly how to do it that was a
big moment for me because I don't think
I ever you had no bad that was
camaraderie that was because everyone's
treating me like a freak and here comes
Zach you know the most normal food
you've ever had to back me up but now
but not like doing that like I've been
doing it so long uh it's not like it's
so weird to wipe the other way I can't
do it no you can possible you [__]
can my it feels like the cheeks are so
tight no and I can't get in there I
can't get into the oh I can't do it you
gotta get the cornhole right you know
scooping brothers forever oh my God like
those tostada scooping chips
Tostitos Tostitos a scoop let's get
scooping brother
I don't know what that would prove to us
I'm a clean I'm very clean
let me get this straight side yeah are
you just saying this to get the job
right out here or something he wouldn't
lie about this you swear he wouldn't lie
about this Sheila it's embarrassing it
is very embarrassing but baby wipes let
me tell you save your life hold on hold
on
back up hang on you're telling me that
you wiped from the back until you heard
this show and then based on my anecdote
you decided to lift your own balls and
dick in one hand reach under them and
scoop out the [__] from the front of us
yeah I do prefer it yes that that blows
my mind then and now because like you
know growing up to teach you how to wipe
and you know mom shows you Dad shows you
I tried him like oh [__] this is game it
makes sense
wow and have any of you guys since tried
it oh no it's crazy the [__] wrong
with you just try it Friday it changed
his life no dude but like the other way
seems counterintuitive also you gotta
stand you got to put your whole arm in
your ass you just said it you have an
intuitive you you wiped the other way
until you were like 22. yeah
the jar wiping method is
counterintuitive you're missing the
point then when you go from the back you
put your whole arm in your ass crack
what yeah you're getting smeared [__]
all over the seat yeah
this is protocol it's safe this is all
you're like this deep into ass crack
when you wipe from the back because you
have to do like this like look how much
of my arm is in my Ashcraft it's
dangerous
you guys have to copy your balls to wipe
what's wrong with that yeah keep them
clean dude then what's wrong what's up
you don't touch your balls love of
course every now and then oh God I think
you're an everyday type of touch in your
balls love well you are definitely all
right well listen we don't need to
rehash uh Old Wounds we have definitely
I think there's gonna be a lot of this
conversation coming up probably
absolutely let it let's bring it on wow
what a what a fun
a fun beginning there so there's gonna
be I think it's gonna be all bangers
come here give me a hug love you
[Applause]
love Zach you're awesome I really
appreciate he has uh turned into quite
quite the young man thank you yes thank
you so Zach Lewis live at the Roxy wow
thank you May 13th yeah
and uh uh let's enjoy when Zach came
onto the podcast we had him start doing
the sound bites and in a few years time
this man has ascended to sound bite
goddam he's known throughout the world
as the sound bite King here's zap the
sound bite Legend love the buffet it's
just
it's you know it's War digital Warfare
and uh mashed potato and gravy and fried
chicken
gotta eat yeah you know Garb up the war
is coming boys we're both get those
carved
[Laughter]
uh
is it just say beer
okay let's hit it let's take a jerk off
to this damn whoa
Dan let's talk about why you said that I
could not say that I was a sound bite
you said I can jerk off sound I can jerk
off to this exactly how's this program
that allows him too I you thought that
was appropriate to say right now little
Snippets of audio and play them back on
demand is what he has done I feel my
pain
I deceived you all he's deceived you all
I have no evidence let's guess what
happened
the shittiest dude on the internet
keemstar although Nick with Kavanaugh to
be honest
let's not forget Ryan Kavanaugh who
falsified uh sexual uh harassment memo
that's good you edited it so it says
that's the problem that's good
surprise
that's good that's good
oh and then there's a new season of mob
psycho 100 like where did that come from
so I'm watching that now the mob
wow Zach how how the [__] did you get
that so fast Jesus the mob
I've been doing this long enough yeah it
was crazy you're I mean it's impressive
man keep it up thank you
[Music]
likewise yeah I was like where the [__]
even are they you know it's Spencer's
Spencer's has like
some toys and stuff too it's a mix it's
weird yeah it's like pop culture
she said it's a lollipop gross
pop right now hey 50s
Vin Diesel what did he say he said talk
to me baby that's so messed up Vin
Diesel this this is dude we gotta put a
line on this in diesel she's so [__]
beautiful
you can't do that I'm laughing because
it's so insane that you're hitting those
sound bites but you can't do that it's
amazing artist named Slinky witch I
actually remember
Jesus what the [__]
what the [__] is wrong with you
that was so inappropriate
Zach that was so [__] up
Zach what the [__]
[Music]
that was not I'm laughing because of how
I'm not laughing
that was so inappropriate
the timing of that was just not okay
[Laughter]
what the [__] is wrong with you dude
I'm sorry Trisha I'm laughing but not
I'm laughing at how obscene that timing
was and not
that's not appropriate
[__] dude why there I'm all places would
you do that
that was so wrong
that was not that was not cool
it's like the puffer fish you know you
got to prepare it right to get all rid
of the little poisons
the puffer fish right the one that turns
into a circle are you [__] serious
how did you do that so fast the goat how
did you hit the puffer fish so
literally and I've never said puffer
fish like ever on this show
I have everything man I was shocked that
one was Scott
got me on that one okay wow thank you I
mean that was fast man upper [__]
puffer fish okay
Magellan back there The Wizard of Oz we
learned something interesting about Zach
though he has an alter ego The Joker
brain he joke her brains so much I think
he he lost control of himself for a
little while here's his Joker brain era
is this the good stuff is this the
mayonnaise of choice the regular smegula
the real man oh you got the oh he got us
the Kroger [__] he's a store Brandy
all right so cheers
there we go
you definitely getting the 500 if you
finish that bro
oh my goodness
wow wow he's in two three bites well
we slowing down he's thinking about it
twice now can I have water with this
no
the water will slow it down too much I'm
afraid you're actually doing really good
yeah I'm impressed that's impressive
four full go ahead take your time
four huge spoons man it's gonna make me
[__] wait I think he had three no oh
well whatever he's got to finish
I don't want to get this [__] in my hair
yeah I don't want mail in your hair
either
oh my goodness he's doing good I'm
impressed holy [__] I thought you
were just gonna I'm like left in there
yeah you're all you still have like
three fourths left
I feel like I could do it though can I
get a warm
but not not I don't want it to slow it
down too much no I won't slow down okay
you get one you get once five bites one
sip it's a little sippy okay there you
go okay
keep it keep it going
no um dude this is how is it rate
against Horsey Sauce yeah it's even
better than Horsey Sauce you want to cut
to our backup plan
is there any chance you might puke the
case of a gag nah
I don't know if we can show them
vomiting we'll probably get uh no I'll
leave the room if that happens
you guys want some let's see it
go ahead
eating it like [__] cereal my dude
[Music]
oh yeah yeah
walk me through this how does it taste
how does it feel like okay
what are you feeling right now a little
gag it's a little bit you're feeling
nauseous
I did she did after like four bucks
I don't I don't think I can do anymore
how much did we get
let me see
we're like halfway or like I mean that's
half I have to tell you we're close I'm
impressed I'm impressed oh my God you
might be able to do a Guinness record oh
[__] like if you actually tried now what
I'd like to know are you are you tapping
out okay well congratulations
I appreciate that of course I'd like to
report back when you have a dump later I
want to know about that you want
pictures no no pics but I want to know
how you're feeling tell me about you you
know okay I mean it did have
two packs of Horsey Sauce gets you yeah
but who knows what's in that you know
well I've never done that before
that was gnarly well this this is this
is good entertainment folks this is what
we do here no it's impressive cheers so
they each play podcasts to Zach the
heroic Zack
um well it's TGIF
cheers if everyone's got a bucket of
mayonnaise at home take a shot you know
enjoy right and live with them we've got
some Veggie Grill backstage that I'm
dying to get to you can be do you feel
fine like because you're selling I'm
okay I mean I want to keep going I could
try okay
I can try man I think I need some more
water though see the squirrel water
thing yeah I think the water messes it
up if you have a second one you can keep
trying but I It's gotta you gotta
commit now do I get 250 for finishing
half no I made it very clear to use that
yeah I said 500 or nothing
[__]
you guys call it should I take another
bite
dude you have all the time you need
if you have a second oh but you got the
veggie grill out there I don't want to
like make this hey we're here I know
we're enjoying yeah we're here to
entertain but but I would say I would
hurt you unless you think you can finish
it I don't want you to punish yourself
for nothing
okay I'm not gonna do it okay I'm
tapping out I'm sorry I failed you no
you didn't fail me honestly I didn't
think you would make it to like half of
that oh you want a guess you want to
take them no I can't remember your
sandwich
I love man
I still you know what [__] it why not
here we go he's going in for another
bite
that texture must be awful you're not
loving that
um
that's glorious tastes like Freedom
let's continue this interview in our
barber shop over here let's go the the
boys were kind enough to honor me with
with the H3 wine so thank you very much
now um Ed go ahead so you're you're the
you're you know what you're doing so
I'll leave it to you now Ed well since
I've got here and you're prepping have
you been to any um coronavirus hot spots
in the last uh 30 days
no you haven't no heck no yeah good
because young Zack here is very worried
about the coronavirus and he was just uh
a little bit nervous about somebody
touching his head today but just for the
record you have not been to Italy Iran
uh China or anything like that no sir
and how long ago in the Philippines
because there is some coronavir what
then
oh I'm too close oh my etiquette is too
good and Philippines I believe there's
some Corona virus there is that right
now but um yeah um but when I was there
I don't think it was it exists it didn't
exist yet uh Zach how are you feeling
okay okay okay there's more they're more
worried about what people are posting
online about the coronavirus than which
is becoming a bigger deal than what it
actually is people are scaring people a
lot so just be careful wash your hands
wash your hands that's Big Ed's advice
yes wash your hands you have any other
advice on how to keep safe from the
coronavirus yes I'm mayonnaise in the
hair
the perfect antidote this is best foods
which I'm a craft man but it's okay okay
oh it doesn't fit the spatula is too big
it doesn't fit in the top so Ed is now
no Ed bring it over here no bring it
over here so we can see on camera it's
right here that's good
absolutely so big Ed is dumping the
mayonnaise on the spatula oh my God we
are and so we have what we have here is
a nice ring of mayonnaise on the spatula
and it's looking beautiful Zach would
you like to smell it before we engage no
oh my God that's a lie okay so don't
worry about making a mess it's totally
fine
and so what one thing you're going to
notice
um Zach is it's gonna be cold so cold
what it's cold okay and the second thing
you're going to notice is it smells like
egg salad sandwiches now Zach go ahead
and and tell me from your experience how
is this going
you know it's not that bad I'll tell you
the truth so let me ask you this it's
very cooling how old are you I'm 22. 22.
do you oh you're a kid oh my God so you
don't die or you don't love dye your
hair no no no no okay but but we all I'm
gonna use the biggest one oh so so big
Ed has reached into the mayonnaise jar
and grabbed a handful of mayonnaise is
this uh comparable to the amount of
mayonnaise you would use on your own
hair um well Zach's hair is actually a
little longer than mine but um yeah this
is about the same you want to make sure
that you you work it in oh my God I'm
gonna get this out
that's a lot of mayonnaise I have to say
but the but we have to moisturize now
how long do you recommend keeping the
mayonnaise in the hair to get maximum
good question half an hour oh okay now
do you find them but you'll find out
dude that after a while you don't even
you don't notice the smell because
you're all of the hair follicles in your
nose they shut down oh yeah you you
acclimate like when you take a stinky
dump and you're on the toilet for 30
minutes they stop um you know the smell
from penetrating okay so what I'm
basically doing hopefully he's not
getting too excited I'm working the
mayonnaise into the scalp that's
important now can you get a close-up
down of the amount of mayonnaise that's
running through Ed's fingers here
because there's quite a bit of
mayonnaise in the do you need more
mayonnaise may I recommend one more here
no how are you feeling oh the smell is
getting to me okay it's supposed to
okay so this you missed the sideburns
this these that needs yeah okay sorry
just to be thorough thorough okay got it
okay here we go all right so now what I
have here is his tail because what
you're gonna I'm gonna pull to the side
please so you can see the tail so I'm
going to take his tail and kind of I'm
gonna actually gonna wrap it into the
top of his head and because it's
mayonnaise it kind of just sticks it's a
natural um adhesive I got a haircut okay
there you go okay more to the side
please there you have okay turn the
other way turn this way so we can see
the tail
and so I basically wrapped the tail back
into his scalp excellent
excellent smile is starting to get to me
well you well
yeah there was a shower cap yeah we also
have hair clips
um I don't think it's going to be
necessary so what about paper towels you
guys got a paper towel good so Dan can
you take this you're done with the
spatula okay
it's important that you measure the size
of your spatula
because it doesn't always fit into the
the jar it's not a big deal I'm not
upset or anything okay Zach turn to me
so now I'm going to clean some of the
mayonnaise off of your skin
no we don't want the mayonnaise to be on
the skin only in the hair is that right
that is correct only because of the odor
okay so Zach I'm gonna have only because
of that odor he said okay okay and can I
ask you a question do you ever take a
taste of the mayonnaise
not at this point okay just you know I
know you I just met you but no I'm
kidding okay no but we we kind of were
talking about that earlier that oh can
you breathe okay sorry
um so
um so what I'm basically doing and this
does a couple things turn this way so
big Ed has put a bag over uh Zach's head
at the moment so what this um what this
does basically is it it it it kills some
of the odor oh it does it has it killed
the odor attack no
okay perfect okay so how do you feel I
got some don't worry about that Zach uh
Big Ed has spilled a big dollop of
mayonnaise behind you but not to work
you don't mind it's for later at this
point you need to take another sip of
wine take a sip of wine okay and how are
you feeling pretty relaxed okay does
anybody have a timer
yeah
okay well
um let's go 15 minutes 15 minutes 15
minutes is that enough yeah that's
enough okay let me ask you a question
um
um what was my question I was going to
ask you a question
forgot anyways all right I'm not
important
um so let's leave it in 50 oh my
question was how are you getting this
out of your hair yeah that's what I want
to do well we have running water and a
sink I'm sure we'll figure it out or you
were welcome to leave it for more now if
not like bleach if you leave mayonnaise
in the hair your hair falls out is there
a similar effect have you left
mayonnaise in your hair for too long I'm
not sure that's a very good question
what's the what's the longest no the you
know I um fell asleep one time drinking
Malbec and I think it was in there for
an hour and a half really didn't notice
you know in effect what's gonna
eventually happen is the whiteness of
the mayonnaise it's going to go away
it's almost gonna be like an oil right
yeah so that's when you're that's when
you really know you should take it out
of here but so when the whiteness goes
it's time to wash correct correct the
important thing though too is that
um how are you doing is that you have to
you have to wash your hair twice if you
don't get it out of your hair and you
show up for work you know the next day
hey your pillow's gonna smell like
mayonnaise and B everybody at work um
wants to know what smells like egg salad
sandwich well well I thank Zach for um
for
I thank you Zach for for putting your
your head in the game so here so this is
the one I just watched you did it with
this mayonnaise you did it with this
mayonnaise yeah oh one's Miracles why
are you red and sweaty
red and sweaty is that on camera right
now he doesn't look sweaty no in The
Tick Tock oh and this one why are you
ready sweaty in the ticket honestly I
feel like it sometimes the lighting just
does that well I also have something
called rosacea where I have like a
chronic red face rosacea oh [__] most
people in the chat just didn't ableism
big time that sounds like here he is
making fun of me so let me ask you guys
make fun of a clinical that's right it's
frozen shot is canceled okay tell me you
have you did one with best
what is it called best uh Hellman's best
food yeah that's that one's Mayo the
other one we watched was Miracle Whip
it's a little different
so why did you did you go to the grocery
store and explicitly buy these for this
video no I'm like because you know I got
like a joker brain and like you know he
kind of [__] up
does that means you want to kill someone
I mean it it does like you shouldn't say
that but you've had these on stock these
I'm like I was like at post dinner like
putting you know help put [__] away and
oh my God there's some mayo I'm like oh
[__] it just [__] it so do you oh so
these were already opened uh correct
yeah the mirror the Miracle Whip
Ian's like oh look at that Ian's what
got Zach as the Joker Ian are you
worried though like for real about the
covet thing like how are you feeling
about it
so I I'm actually not familiar with Lego
uh I can't voiced by Zach Galifianakis
really yeah
I've never watched it like I honestly
can't comment so I'll just put him see
it seems pretty fair
well what do you think have you seen the
the movies Zach
uh yeah I mean I've seen everything
related to Joker Joker brain Joker lore
Ian do me a favor will you catch will
you read a review of um Zach galifin
acid fanax Joker from The Lego Movie
Zach Galifianakis
his Joker come on man
so let's see what the critics had to say
about it now what how we're replacing
Zach
I'd say like D or E tier oh [__] you
damn yeah I'll put you above Jared
you're gonna you're gonna do me like
that what do you want what I'm gonna lie
and just be you know give you this where
do you see yourself friends favor yeah
I'm [__] eighth here dude at least
you're on the same you're on the same
level as Jack Nicholson bro I live this
life back here we're in a joker match
from Target bro no I'm not from Target
it's from Amazon thank you very much
worse
you can uh here's a review of Zack's
galifianakis's Joker he said his gleeful
kid-friendly Joker was just as adorable
as he was crazy probably the least
intimidating version you will ever see
sounds like babe I don't like him oh
okay he's outshined by his on-screen
Batman who is much funnier
you get upstaged by yeah it's like a d
that sounds like a d to me
[Applause]
hey people really like that huh
apparently Lego got like a whole Dynasty
that I'm not aware of like the games
movies people really love these Legos
yeah these Legos I haven't seen the one
the Joker one but that original Lego
movie was fantastic
so Zach with peace and love I mean let's
let's be honest bro you know Zach
nobody you're on your own League of your
own but that's [__] up man you know
you want an F no I can you put me at
least a B I mean look at look at me
there's no [__] way here B look at my
poise you know your Poise yeah I don't
think the joker I'm putting you here or
you could just barely see the image
did me dirty dude why does this look
like Zach who is this so as I was
explaining craft mayonnaise
has thrown down the gauntlet
and as you know Zach our resident sacks
the sound lad is a connoisseur of
mayonnaise
look at that yes sir look at that look
at his background here let me show you
first of all they put out this Con this
contest they said prove your love to win
the next craft Mayo endorsement
here's hitting Mayo straight out of the
jar who I remember somebody doing that
at a real game is this him or is this
like a reenactment
who is this guy okay so there was some
Legend and the audience at a game eating
Mayo at the jar yeah
that was the best thing ever look at
this Legend
so anyway they say all right well you
know here's one hero but where's the
next hero hungrier than ever
do you have what it takes to win the
next Mayo endorsement
move it
so they say prove it
#craft mail endorsement hashtag contest
I love contests like oh yeah the only
content in the world yeah I think craft
mail endorsement is specific enough
#lol
it's like food
and make sure to include a hashtag uh
salami sandwich
[Music]
you doing today my name is Zach Lewis
also known as Zach The Sound Lab
a day in Southern California today I'm
going to show you why I am the true
mailman and why I should win from crap
the Mayo endorsement
you can see all the Mayo things I've
done eating it raw I put mayonnaise in
my hair with the help of Big Ed dressed
up as the Joker I put mayonnaise on my
face for a Christmas special who else
does that today is the ultimate
Challenge
bathtub full of mayonnaise
wow that was a dramatic
and now for the massive Mayo movement
we've all been waiting for
yes you see that right it's a kiddie
pool oh a [__] mayonnaise
Kraft mayonnaise
that's all craft Manning man the finest
mayonnaise in the world may I add crabs
mayonnaise
crap which brand is it number one brand
looking craft mayonnaise baby let's go
you know where to get it you know what
it is
high quality craft manner hear that baby
[Music]
oh yeah
oh this feels nice
yo those are handfuls
I'm the real mailman okay real craft
Mayo endorsement hey you want some dude
you sure yeah I'm pretty sure
you want to come shake my hand thank you
yeah yeah there it goes all right now
that's a Superman
you're my Superman oh that's sweet got a
sandwich in there
it's a gooey here it comes here comes
give it a squeeze
there we go
big head and have [__] on this oh yeah
that's what I'm talking about let's take
another bite from the real craft
mayonnaise
I'm hungry actually
oh there you go oh my goodness Gracie
oh yeah then we're down now babe you're
about to make me act up Jack
[Music]
yeah
let's go real craft mayonnaise
loves me
outside please oh Jesus
we got the power washer out
[Music]
try to be gentle
touch
or your consideration
hashtag craft mail endorsement contest
Zach loves craft and hashtag
um potato salad I don't know
man how do we lose this
thanks for watching
the greatest male ever made okay listen
we've got another huge announcement here
and okay I'm somewhat conflicted on this
I I don't know how to okay well let's
just let's just say it straight craft
mail
did the what I think is
unfortunately the inevitable
they excluded Zach where's the initial
tweet where they show the finalists but
it is interesting they they sent you
this I wonder if they sent this to other
people or if they just trying to appease
you Zach what do you think well I find
it they sent it to the podcast Twitter I
never received a message on my personal
page oh yeah but we submitted it from
the podcast how are they supposed to oh
okay yeah that's fair enough Zach's
finding any reason to get pissed off now
they didn't hunt me down
um
it's it's look
it is what it is but I'm not happy and
Zach's downplaying it he had a [__]
meltdown when he found out about that we
have a video of him it's really not an
exaggeration well let me read the
message they messaged our podcast
Twitter Hey at the H3 podcast thank you
for submitting your entry to become our
next craft Mayo uh Mayo dorschment we
appreciate all the time and dedication
put into videos like yours they didn't
say years by the way they said we
appreciate the time and dedication put
into videos like yours
not a direct compliment no it's a total
snub
while your submission did not become a
top eight finalist we are happy to
recognize your originality
personality and of course Zach your
passion for craft mail yeah I am passion
as an honorable mention this title will
get you an exclusive craft made an
endorsement t-shirt did we provide our
mailing info for that no I mean I don't
want to spoil it because it's in the
video but we we had somewhat of a Curt
response oh no
we're the war has begun well this is
where it gets interesting they say
here's a free t-shirt and then they also
offer a year's supply of craft mail now
I'm very curious what does that mean
because they've seen how we use mayo and
we bathe in it so I'm wondering how far
can we stretch a year's supply of mail I
mean it's such a [__] you to us like
it's like oh here you go here's a
[__] t-shirt you know I mean it's
literally a consolation press yeah [__]
them to redeem your price please let us
know the best address to send it to
thanks again for showing up and showing
off your love for Mayo yeah bastards
I kind of knew this was coming you know
maybe maybe okay hear me out
I know we're like ruining their contest
and the thing is if you got in the top
eight you would definitely win by a
landslide right so I'm wondering if
they're just trying to be fair about it
or I'll be honest with you Zach maybe
they knew you weren't using real craft
mail in the [__] swimming pool it's
about time we come clean on that why
would you admit that what what what are
you talking about you already lost Zach
the gig is up The Jig Is up it's [__]
over dude you're not winning [__]
Dan went and bought a like yeah they
don't sell uh at Costco gallons of uh
craft making maybe they knew they're
like that's not craft mail you think I'd
bathe in their [__] product
not real craft Hellman's you would use
right of course or maybe like Nature's
or what is the there's like that class
one best something fast food yeah Best
Foods is kind of the icon I uh yeah and
I I say in my rant that I am a Hellman's
boy now and craft can go [__] themselves
rough well let's let's watch the video
because uh so here's Zach's genuine
reaction I don't think he's playing this
up when the hammer came down it was big
news when they tweeted out the finalists
and we're like Zack's not there I
[__] called it I knew they weren't
going to include you
they've been snubbing you all month well
they sent the DM before they put out the
um the finalists well they're clearly
scared of the male War that's Brewing
they know what's coming
I'm just confused because it's like on
one hand they want the publicity right
which we gave them out the [__]
Wazoo we're like the only our audience
is the only people paying attention to
this like who the [__] cares about craft
male social media no one when have any
of you guys ever out there interacted
with a mayonnaise social media website
and by the way to what end who gives a
[__] I I had a bit of a conspiracy that
the bar stool connection I found
interesting
yeah we we've got to talk about the bar
stool connection okay let's watch Zach's
reaction then we can talk about the bar
stool conspiracy
but okay are the finalists Barstool
Associated Ian
no I mean we'll watch the video okay
here here's Zach's uh
unfettered response
I missed it it's the podcast
thank you for submitting your entry to
become our next
we appreciate all the time and
dedication put into videos like first
[Music]
[Applause]
we are happy to recognize your
originality Zach spent that money man oh
really
yeah
[Music]
this title will get you an exclusive
hashtag craft Mayo dorsman T-shirt oh
[__] [__] you hey and your supply of
craft mail hey a your supply [__] you
crap my voice crack nice [__] you and
now I gotta keep it in God damn it all
right for showing up and showing off
your love for Mayo sincerely Team Real
craft mail hey team realcraft now right
there right there [__] okay and I'm
true I'm admitting this right now and
this is true show my phone yeah I love
Dan's response Dan just writes you just
made the biggest mistake of your life
of your lives a threat on all of them
[__] you craft mayonnaise he let them
know he let them know
[__] crap man I said you just made
the biggest mistake yeah all right is
there so I think we got is there should
I keep watching
there were maybe uh kind of calm me down
if you wanna you walked you off well
that's not funny
um back there we've got Zacky
come fully committed
how do you feel oh fantastic let's put
on a happy face shall we
I'm also what's the line from Chet Hanks
give him a run for his money uh
um it's a lot it's like when a dog it's
called a car he doesn't know what to do
with it
Chasing Cars I wouldn't know what to do
if I got it I'm like a dog chasing cars
I wouldn't know what to do if I got it
very good very good bravo bravo thank
you thank you thank you Bravo I'm also
known as the Joker my Star of David so
I'm doing it I'm doing a circumcision
bar mitzvah's uh weddings he's also
Irish for some reason yeah yeah the
Irish part I can't say I understand but
it's green yes it is green yes the Joker
The Joker yeah that's the new one yeah
yeah
what did you say Zach I said you've
never done that have you [__] in a
flower bed
I've shot on some dude lawn before why
did you do that okay so it's when I was
in school and it was very early in the
morning and the shits hit me on the
freeway
and I get off and I'm looking for a gas
station or something and there's nothing
it's all residential area
so I literally had to [__] on some
dude's lawn I had no choice I tried
[__] my pants in the car but my body
would just not let me
okay so so hold on pay me a painted
picture for me okay and you're driving
you're in the residential yeah and then
so it's just like some random guy his
grass like just you like you would
imagine a normal house with a normal
front yard with grass like you know and
how how far up into the grass did you go
to dump uh three feet it was early in
the morning so I knew no one was up like
5 a.m no it was like eight oh eight and
people are definitely on paid dude I was
in and out in 10 seconds and like it was
just running down my legs it was [__]
awful and so when you so you went about
three feet into the grass you just
squatted and then just let everything go
and then ran back in the car and bounce
yep that's it man can you imagine
getting there I took off your fence and
everything wait I Dr I dropped them like
below the knees and just how old were
you uh this was I was a few months ago
this this was probably about two years
ago oh
kind of like a few months ago pretty
much
wait were you working for us uh yeah it
was uh pretty early on but yeah
were you on your way into work were you
on were you on your way to work no I was
I was on my way to an 8 A.M class and I
was trying to write coffee that morning
and I'm like [__] so wait hang on hang
on hang on
do you know what why you had such crazy
diarrhea did you eat something the day
before I think it was the coffee that
did it because coffee just coffee alone
ain't gonna make you [__] on someone's
lawn bro no no dude my coffee [__] my
stomach up man oh can we get some coffee
you see I'm not on Fizz I just want
coffee now by the way my gerd is doing
much better you guys may have noticed
great so let's drink coffee and ruin it
can you get some yeah thank you
Zach this is an incredible story you you
were on your way to school when this
happened
yeah I was on my way to school and I'm
on the 118 freeway and all of a sudden I
feel my stomach drop and I'm like I'm I
have to [__] I have to [__] [__] and
so wait so there's a chance that someone
would have recognized you too because
like they would know you from the show
I think it was too early on but if
someone had like a ring of Zach from the
H3 podcast [__] on my lawn would be the
greatest thing ever I think that's a
personal act Zach
yeah yeah it was it was [__] gnarly
but my stomach just [__] hurt but
what can you do I mean sometimes Nature
Calls as they say I could my body or
like [__] there was nothing there was
nothing so so you're on your way to
school did you did you go to school no I
went home there was [__] just running
down my legs how did it smell in the car
was there smell it was fantastic it's
just like you know that [__] diarrhea
smell fantastic yeah and you didn't go
to school that day did you no I didn't
yeah I went home is that one of the
worst things that ever happened to you
uh I think so I think definitely one of
them you said and you said you went home
and cried yeah I know we cried about it
did you tell anyone about it yeah my
family and friends I mean I'm not
embarrassed of it I wear it like a badge
of honor but yeah
that on some dude's lawn did you cry so
did you just go home and like Cry by
yourself for a little bit before you
yeah I did
did you ever think about going back and
telling him hey I shot on your lawn I'm
sorry
so I actually went back the next day and
the turd was like dispersed
[Laughter]
what does that mean like they tried to
hose it down yeah it was still there so
what were you gonna do were you just
curious or were you going there to try
to help out I was just curious what it
looked like with the aftermath was it's
like they say like sir like murderers
return to the scene of the crime right
exactly some sociopath [__]
laughs
wow yeah what what did you what did you
feel when you went back and saw it uh I
was pretty proud of it to tell you the
truth
I can't imagine like how do you just the
world is so strange man world is so
strange yeah but I guess I guess hearing
it from your side it kind of does make
sense it's like what are you supposed to
do I mean that's happened to me before I
didn't [__] I would never I don't think
I would go out and [__] in someone's
lawn my pants yeah me too
I wouldn't think to be like I'm the [__]
on this dude's lawn I mean that's kind
of wild but this girl's [__] in the
flower bed so
I used to sneak booze and Cuban cigars
when I went on a cruise oh Zach you're a
cruise uh veteran I know that time of my
life on a cruise I think it's fun for
kids and old people
I was 15 I told everyone I was 17.
that's actually pretty cool because you
got to drink and smoke and stuff like
you would never be able to do yeah yeah
plus that's when I lost my v card what
on a cruise yeah we've I told this story
you didn't tell me that story that was
like the whole uh blood thing with the
popping of the hymen you didn't connect
how was I supposed to know that
was on a cruise bro how did you seduce a
girl wait hold on did you meet her on
the cruise yes it was like where was it
too uh it was Caribbean Wait hold on you
met her on the cruise she was from
England too and you took her virginity
uh no she took my virginity but why was
her highness yeah broken no no yeah yeah
so she's a virgin then yeah yeah
what you guys took each other's
virginity on a cruise yeah that's cool
and then you never saw each other no
what oh my God maybe she's watching
right now Zach how did you meet her how
did you seduce this girl how did you I
mean I I brought me everything I brought
my guitar and so I was like
a good time how did you first meet her
where did you meet her so they have like
a a club thing and it's funny it was a
Princess Cruise too and that's the one
that's like in all the heat right now
did you call her a princess
um and like they had like Club things
and you know you just go around and
you're up till four in the morning or at
least I was
and I would just take my guitar all over
the cruise and just play and try and get
her attention
it was like during New Year's too and
like there was a dude playing bagpipes
as well and like that guy never had a
shot no was your room also like a prison
completely yeah okay but wait wait wait
you had your own room because I'm
imagining you're with your parents well
no no so it was my grandmother went my
parents and then my brother and I had
our own room but once I started like you
know I met this girl I kicked my brother
out of the room I had to go sleep with
my parents and your branch knew what was
going on uh I I would assume yeah
because why would their brother be with
them
yeah exactly your parents knew you were
you were screwing some girl on the
cruise yeah I mean my dad was cool with
it
well
that's great that's a pretty gnarly
story Zach and did you guys have did you
guys do it more than once or was it just
traumatic and then you never did it
again uh it was traumatic and did it one
time oh no because it was like I didn't
know what was going on you know what it
was she how was she off did you talk to
her afterwards uh yeah I mean it was
like I mean I wasn't like a dick I was
like yeah it happens you know no but
like the app so so you guys have this
really crazy Oh you mean like last
stayed friends yeah
you like she got kind of weird and
wanted to start like dating me and [__]
like you got clingy on there you got
super [__] clingy on the cruise where
is she gonna go
you're on a cruise I don't know you guys
had sex
wait it's weird that she wanted to be
with you after you took her virginity
well well but she maybe she was just
being really like like really clingy
I mean but you were stuck on the cruise
so even on the cruise you're like listen
baby you were kind of standoffish listen
princess
I was like you know I was 15 she thought
I was 17 you know oh
um
I mean yeah so so wait you guys had this
night the next day she's
intensely uh wanting to be with you yeah
and then your reaction was was what you
know it wasn't like a dick I was nice
but like I just kind of distanced myself
hung out with others you know you know
she has distrust of men ever since
I think he's single and I crushed this
girl fantastic now now why is it you
didn't want to spend any time with her
you just weren't into her and you were
just over it I was freaked out by the
situation yeah I understand I understand
I totally understand that
wow yeah so
um cruises are crazy and I like I met
all these people from like Canada and
England were you trying to smash other
girls yeah oh man you are a wild man and
did your parents even ask you like what
was what happened well I I they saw me
walking around with my guitar and like
talking to other girls so they had to
assume what was going on
wow wow did you smash any other girls on
the cruise no it was just a few kisses
here and there but dude
I know I know God damn you're bald young
man I thought you were weren't you
pretty big back then yeah I was I was
very big wow I was I was I was a
freshman in high school nice memory then
thank you dude thank you for bringing
that yeah well I think it is it is a
good detail yeah and I I you know I was
bullied in high school so yeah
um
this was a pretty uh Awakening and then
came back to my stride man yeah for you
then came back to you know my shitty
life in high school and you know you're
like dude I [__] like 20 girls on this
group nobody believed you yeah so so
wait
was this girl did you was she trying to
get in touch with you during that whole
time I mean was she just kind of went
her separate way when you were flirting
with other girls uh yeah she kind of
took the hint and you know
made like a tree and leave you know
damn dude wow I wasn't a dick I wasn't
like get the [__] out of my face it was
just like well that would be insane
Zach this is an incredible story wow
do you think about her do you ever feel
bad about how that went down I do feel
bad how that went down but I also feel
bad for myself because I was a very
traumatic situation yes you were
definitely the victim
I feel bad for you Zach
oh my goodness this is incredible this
is such an incredible story yeah this
episode is gone everywhere
they are totally off the road we are at
break time oh my goodness I don't want
to stop sorry there's a conversation is
just well Zach is the Zach I love you
buddy you you give and you give I was
such a nerd at that age like it's crazy
he tried to come back
it's crazy he tried yeah but it didn't
work raised another yeah he raised
another Army yeah but he got owned
didn't he swim back wasn't that that is
definitely not true I could tell you my
history teacher [__] me man I can tell
you as someone who has a very poor
understanding of everything that that he
did not swim back
I heard differently
exactly let me probe deeper here
Napoleon swam
from an island and an exiled Island to
France
and then raise the army
Google he's a g dude I mean come on oh
my god dude no I think somebody and
let's let's let's get back on shame you
were looking that up he didn't swim come
on who are we kidding I want to know if
he swam I think he swam dude no he
didn't
okay look it up no he was definitely
someone came in the night and picked him
up and all this [__]
bro you don't swim like 100 miles if
you're just some dude
Gila are you uh able to find anything
about Napoleon swimming
so I tried to just control F swim and
then come on
here just say did Napoleon swim bro he
swam dude yeah are you [__] with me
did Napoleon
swim from Elba or european fans
Napoleon escape from Elba are you ready
Zach Americans it's gonna be swimming
dude it says he swam
a 260 kilometers away from the French
[__] border dude
you can swim that
people swim the English Channel so yeah
but he's it's not pulling dude pure
willpower he just did it just made it
happen
but so what happens when he gets on the
on the coast after his crazy swim he
just goes immediately raises an army
exactly
uh anyway Napoleon swam Napoleon was the
greatest swimmer ever I mean [__] yeah
it was
a little Shane [__]
[__] that's so sidetracked
so Shane is exiled like um Napoleon is
what I was meaning to say either what
are you typing so furiously are still
in this the swimming no because I see
that he
he sneaked out over there but they don't
say somebody came with a boat and picked
his ass up at night probably I'm seeing
the Elba island is not far from the
coast
I told you it's 150 miles he swam people
swim
uh yeah do you know how far Alcatraz is
from San Francisco I I don't know look
up the distance okay
tell me the distance and remember elba's
150 miles it's definitely not 150 miles
you can you can skip the looking up it's
not 150 miles tell me the distance
of Alcatraz half a mile half a mile Zach
4.6 miles
might as well be the same thing
I thought of a story all right let's
hear it on someone's lawn no no no
um which I'm not cringing at I'm still
very proud of that yes I don't know why
but
um but we love you for that you know I'm
known as a very cringe person and you
know a lot of things I do I just I just
do I don't find them cringy
um this story The Joker brand yes which
in itself is cringed to a lot of people
but whatever no it's cool yeah it is
this story makes me cringe so this says
a lot that's okay so I was about 15.
and I had a horrible case of swamp ass
now if you've ever had that it's a
horrible thing it's very what is swamp
asset it's like you know you find your
term yeah
um you know you had a long day of like
diarrhea or whatever and your [__] is
just raw and oh your cheeks are red and
you know what have you I thought swamp
out was just sweaty ass but this is
you're talking about you there was
dramatic kind of uh experience at your
ass there was there was sweat involved
yes yeah it was a full whammy okay so I
had this and the
same night we were going to an event it
was one of my dad's clients
and
um
I I needed something for pain relief
um so I put this product on like a a
Vaseline but it's called Rosebud and it
helped with the chafing Rosebud yeah it
helped with the chafing and I caked this
[__] on like finger red on your butthole
yeah so you went to the bathroom and
just put it right on right on in your
ass this was before we were leaving oh
okay okay you know on the cheeks all
that yep and you know it was during
summer so it was a hot night you know uh
we go to the event and the guy's like
hey like you want to go for a ride in my
new Ferrari and it's a beautiful 458
Ferrari gorgeous and I'm like yeah sure
so we go in I'm in the car I'm sitting
there and you know like Ian's story it
was hot
and I started Ian's story it was hot it
was hot yeah interesting I feel this
like squish
as I'm sitting in the car as we're
riding around and yeah
um
I'm like what is that totally forgot
that I put the rosebud on Rosebud and
I'm wearing shorts
and I get up out of the car and I see on
the seats
the whole
where you sit is just covered in this
grease and
[Applause]
[Laughter]
just Rosebud and I'm horrified oh
thank God when we got out of the car the
dude didn't see it
but he knew
I'm not at the moment no but he I'm sure
later on he knew I never I never heard
mail trailer
what is wrong with this kid he left he
left
holy [__] so I still cringe at that
probably stunk too oh yeah oh yeah so he
must have thought you were like the most
vile kid he's ever met he this kid left
a stinky grease Trail on my brand new
car man that's awesome I uh yeah that
that horrifies me I've never heard a
word from him or my dad about it did it
look was it like just did it look like
your ass and legs or was it just grease
everywhere it was Grease everywhere wow
what
so the back of your pants must have been
all wet and greasy
[Music]
oh dear also there's another layer to
this but maybe there's maybe there's
multiple uh Rosebud creams or something
I I was just curious because I never
heard of this brand before so I just
Googled Rosebud cream and the first
result is an organic vulver and vaginal
skin care is that what you use that's
not it no are you sure 150 sure okay it
does look like they have some other
brands that's just the first thing that
comes up on Google this is like a
Vaseline like a lip balm but you use it
for like okay okay I was wondering if
that'd be [__] funny though yeah
but yeah that that story makes me cringe
yeah that's bad yeah I'm glad that makes
you cringe I would question your sanity
if that didn't make you cringe
so that's my story okay guy you must
have used a lot of that product Oh I
caked it on because this is what I'm
seeing and I don't know exactly what it
was but like I'm just thinking you'd
have to use a lot of Vaseline to get
that I was hurting that day dude damn
like it was bad Rosebud Salve yeah
that's it that's okay that's the stuff
okay yeah let's see what this is Smith's
Rosebud salve
a trade secret blend of essential oils
cottonseed oil and a special and a
special petroleum base
perfumes so it must has had a it must
have had a nice Rosy shitty like that's
exactly set it seeped through my
underwear it seeped through the shorts I
mean it was just horrifying
horrifying yeah you got you
you got the best stories buddy I mean
that with the [__] on the grass is
just which that doesn't I don't cringe
that I'm very proud of that story why
are you proud of [__] on someone's
grass how many people how many people
can say they did that a lot like
homeless people like every homeless
person I don't know but when you're in a
predicament when you're on your way to
somewhere and your stomach is dropping
and you can't hold it what are you gonna
do you can't hold it I would rather [__]
my pants than drop challenge [__] if you
remember in my story I I tried shooting
my pants in the car it my body why'd you
have to do it on the grass do it in the
gutter or something I it was the only
place I found
I hopped off the freeway and I'm like I
gotta go now
glad you can live with yourself you
gotta go you gotta go I suppose final
moments and the reflections I have a
[__] draft save that I will never
share man oh come on now you have to I
have to no you have to post it right now
and I'll pull it up
post it right now I don't know if it'll
be offensive or not man it's like
talking about a girl and I I don't know
I'll post it right now okay
fine thanks so much [__] for this nah
we're not vetting it we're going live
yeah we're doing it
oh for [__] sake hey what do you do
for a living
yeah I'm a bad [__] with no ass got him
what the [__]
I thought you was bad dude
yeah a bad [__] with no ass got him
hey what do you do for a living
I'm a bad [__] with no ass
god dude the memory is crazy
hang on do we break this down or do we
just forget about it
yeah a bad [__] with no eyes
the way you deliver the Gotham hey what
are you like so [__] serious dude oh
[__] oh [__]
I'm so glad we found this oh man this is
gonna go viral I I should have voted it
and I like it oh I liked it
stomach hurts
holy [__] dude
Zach what are we doing here okay here we
go we meet again men of culture
I'm sorry but I [__] love ass so much
it's not even a point
also in the dark still like why would
anyone want to watch that like what's
the entertainment value of that Tick
Tock my reaction to it that's what
everyone's thinking
okay well let's let's go right to the
The Narcissist let's see who scored the
highest
all right well
um it turns out
the second highest score with a 28 out
of 40 is back we know it we all knew it
Zach you narcissistic piece of [__] we
[__] knew it okay I
my friend okay I you just think you're
so good looking don't you no I I'm
deeply insecure about myself in many
years you should get all the girls don't
you no no no the truth be told I'm
deeply insecure about myself my body
image so so either listen to that that
that's part of narcissism
and this is why there should be sympathy
and not you know I'm kidding we love
Zach no let's hear it let's hear it
though
a very tender core that they protect by
putting an atlas pseudo self on top of
themselves if they get the world to feed
themselves to protect the core right and
that's really how I think of narcissism
is more on the borderline thing so
there's other stuff going on but I think
Zach just described really what I think
of as narcissism
he just said he was insecure for Craig
okay go ahead let's hear where his uh
let's hear where he where he scores off
the chart for us yeah
okay so
um on Authority he got a five out of
eight
um on superiority he got a five out of
five oh wait read those questions a five
out of five on superiority Zach I love
it
so I'm superiority the questions were
when people compliment me I get
embarrassed or I know that I'm a good
person because everybody keeps telling
me so
you know that reminds me that that
reminds me because Zach always tells us
anecdote how when he goes to the grocery
store he's asked the cashier how's her
day going and he thinks that makes her
day better
and we all laugh because we're like she
doesn't give a [__] if you ask cause her
Day you gotta you gotta put a smile on
someone's face
okay keep going Dr Young all right
um the next question I am no better or
no worse than most people or I think I
am a special person
I think you're a special person well
thank you
clearly so do I
[Laughter]
how are you feeling Zach like on a real
level or do you does does this affect
you I mean obviously we're not taking it
too seriously but I'm just kind of
curious
uh I knew I wasn't like other people
interesting
so uh there's that so when you say you
mean so when you a b is has excused
himself
um so when you say you knew you weren't
like other people do you mean
I guess what do you mean by that like
how how did you see yourself as
different than other people
I'm always willing to do something
somebody else doesn't want to do it
could be an attention thing it could be
a I don't know what it is but yeah I'm
Joker brand but I love it I love your
Joker brain I'm Joker brand of I'm gonna
have to get through life now you know
it's gonna be a struggle but you know
I'm gonna do it God willing it was good
oh by the way it was really good thank
you thank you yeah that was a full intro
no it was fun it was good thank you
uh Zach are you wearing a shirt that
says goat yeah well don't call him Zach
yeah you can't call him whenever I wear
this shirt I go by Lou yeah he's Lou
today and then when that when we're not
wearing that shirt we do not know Hulu
is yeah we completely and and why are
you available today I'm just Lou because
lose the goat dude yeah Lou I am good so
so Zach is not the God no Zach Zach's
cool but lose the goat okay and so you
can have Zach when I'm not wearing this
shirt and what makes Lou the goat I just
am the goat you just are yeah did you
see the shirt that he's wearing yeah I
it was it says goat right yeah you can
call me Lou Lou took over my Twitter
account yeah you know before goat became
greatest of all time I used to whenever
I heard goat I would think of goat
goatsy
yeah yeah so
um so yeah you can refer to me as Lou
today okay I'm not gonna do that
but I'm the goat okay you can be the
goat okay I can't guarantee I'm gonna
remember to call you big Louie Louie
yeah confusing Zach to be fair well it's
only when I wear the shirt so yeah you
want to do it all the time this is
confusing can we just pick one name
please and stick with that
maybe if it said Lou the shirt said Lou
the man yeah that would be that would be
make more sense Lou means goat so uh I'm
going bowling later so right you know
I'm the goat
okay yeah Roger that whatever you say
there Louie boy yes there you go
that's Barbara thank you there it is Lou
the goat ladies and gentlemen thank you
respect his nouns
just before we jump into that
where's Zach
where is Zach I didn't even notice he
was going
shouldn't there be some fact
that
I don't hear any like claps and stuff
yeah or the sound bites yeah well let's
just do the show and then okay if she
shows up maybe he's pooping
okay maybe he's having issues all right
shout out Zach
what's that
[__]
this is laughter
[Laughter]
hahaha
foreign
all right welcome Zach everybody
Zach
The Joker what is what is this Zack
you're overcompensating a bit after Lena
challenged your Joker Supremacy what's
what's the strategy here oh there's no
challenge
well she did challenge you actually yeah
she did no she definitely challenged you
yeah but
there's no challenge Zach Have you
reading ass yes I have and then we've
already covered that we did this is
covered territory right okay yeah and
did she shower directly before was it a
Heat of the Moment
after a hike
no [__] way are you kidding no I'm
not kidding what you ate ass after a
hike bro
holy [__] yeah yeah how did it taste
fantastic holy [__] that's why I'm
saying I'm a sick
dude ate ass after a hike yeah yeah
um no it was a you know it was a nice
temperature 75 degrees okay that doesn't
matter it's a [__] hike
could you tell if she wiped really good
before or not oh my God yeah yeah yeah
yeah there was no poop
no no poo poo not even like residual
probably a little residual definitely
residual yeah it was it was you know
it's just like an ass smell you know
it's like a good ass smell
hey [__] it I mean I mean no I think I
think if why not you know what I think
uh bless him yeah God bless him I think
there's a lot of women that are like
appreciate that he's willing to do that
yeah yeah I mean a lot not but a lot yes
yeah you should put it on your Tinder
profile I will eat ass after a hike I
will eat I will eat your ass after I
kiss another thing about Zach besides
the fact that he's a little bit of a
psychopath and a sound bite Legend he is
actually an insanely good musician as
well he shreds super hard on the guitar
he made the Frenemies theme song The
Leftovers theme song he's made a bunch
of ditties and fun little clips and
sound bites for the show that are
original to Zach let's take a look so
this kind of brings us to the end of the
presentation and we got one final
message that I've got here to share with
you guys
uh to wrap it all up
you're listening to the H3 podcast what
we got on the scene could be I'm out
[Music]
are we gonna get sued
oh my god wow I had a little bit of
chills you got chills I did did because
Jay-Z just wrote a song for us yeah then
I sent it to Zach and Zach made the
instrumental yo you made the
instrumental Zach
whoa
crew original oh wait how did you
so Zach you made the music to the lyrics
yeah so uh I mean this is Ian's thing
you know this is totally Ian's thing but
he uh he sent me the AI lyrics and there
were multiple sets and Ian's like make a
Jay-Z style beat and I did able to put
the drones the bass and piano and you
guys ah that was so impressive seriously
that song was I feel like I've been
under a human experience right now all
right experiment yeah because like I
knew it was fake and there's nothing no
meaning in it but I still feel like
Jay-Z wrote a song for us yeah but the
music was sick as well wow I'm impressed
good job everyone you know Zach made
these really fantastic Ian back there
was a meme Ian's got a pee so bad which
you haven't really used in a while
but
um
Zach made two parody songs so anyway the
first one is Ian's flow okay but of
course uh Even Flow by Pearl Jam and
about Ian's uh urinating habits
[Music]
[Applause]
hey Zach did you write all the songs or
was that just like a karaoke piece form
the drums are programmed but I played
the guitar the bass
wow wow wow what a legend and then
another one Ian don't pee it over
[Music]
we gotta upload these I think we have to
upload these to uh separately to the
Highlight Channel
all right let's get on with the contest
all right okay okay so we put together
um where we have a theme song are you
ready I'll roll it foreign
[Music]
you're
a clown
your rough snake
you're a fake Fox 2020 and happy 2021
everybody we'll see you in 2021 we love
you all thanks for coming on this crazy
Journey with us and here's to another
great year ahead H3 podcast forever
we're not going anywhere foot soldier
Army yeah let's go I'm so wonderful
this was gonna be the one excitement
[Music]
we were having fun
and all of a sudden in another land
people were getting sick
we were scared
[Music]
still the [__] inside
at the Joker brand right there if I've
ever seen one
[Music]
Bravo actually if I can plug something
something's coming up on the 30th
Dan can I plug it
uh you talking about your show yeah of
course you could plug it hell yeah April
April 30th live at the mint
links on my story
live at the man gonna be a kick-ass show
check it out it's gonna be flavorful
what are you talking about I'm playing
some tunes and
um
Zach Lewis live with the men
oh yeah
Zach Lewis live at the men April 30th
this Saturday night Link in my Instagram
bio Zach you have your show tomorrow
yeah or you want to you want to plug it
uh yeah tomorrow night live at the mint
uh April 30th 9 p.m live at the man paid
event paid event yeah are you getting
paid uh yeah yeah yeah can I call them
out now or after the event Zach
call them after after okay
you don't want Andy Dick there no I
don't want Auntie dick there kind of
hype
no he'll he'll ruin there's even a
Family Guy bit about Andy Dick showing
up and like it [__] everything up
well that's exciting you've got a paid
event yeah it's fun good for you buddy
thank you thank you it's you know it's
not like insane it's just I'm up there
to just play yeah yeah and uh yeah share
share the love of music
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
there's something else that you should
know about Zach is that he's very
superstitious he freaks out he thinks
that if he listens or heaters or even
listens people mention the name
Cleveland's Klein water revival that he
will be cursed his weak will be cursed
but that's not it he's afraid of Birds
the dark curses ghosts and basically uh
everything here's Zach the skate the
scaredy cat but I have to touch on
something really bizarre I learned this
morning yeah and forgive me Zach
I have to this is just so odd please I
beg I beg you
I'm sorry okay so bizarre okay can you
tell me why you feel this way
okay
it's bad luck I'm not saying I don't
like the music I'm not saying that
it's every time it comes on something
bad happens huh and you think I'm I'm
sure okay crazy I'll disprove that what
you nobody even knows what we're talking
about yeah well
I'm not saying it well we haven't
explained yet because tell me tell me
bad things that have happened when that
when this when their music goes on
um car accidents something bad happens
to someone
speeding tickets just a weird [__]
day just like all
so there's a specific band a very famous
band that Zach feels is absolutely
cursed and he freaks out when I say it
or play it or he hears it anywhere for
example a b
you were driving tell me tell me what
you were telling before we went live
yeah we were going to the uh Marco VA
concert a while ago and I put on uh
Credence Clearwater oh you mother [__]
yeah I was gonna say it Zach we were
jamming out he like turned off my radio
and he's like don't do that and I was
like I thought I like did something
against his religion or something but
yeah he freaked out so what is the band
I because I'm not familiar with it it's
just like a classic rock band okay
I really beloved one yeah
Zach would have been a big fan of Zach
if we if we can't even say like the
initials of the name yeah I I can't even
I can't even no no just the Landers well
Zach can I just can I just I kind of
want to get in your head a little bit
because you say every time I play
something bad happens I mean the fact
that you listen to it with a b and
nothing bad happened kind of disproves
that doesn't it
well you have a five second grace period
oh really yeah what you're making it
immediately I'm gonna turn that [__] off
right now like I'm I was dead seriously
well AB did you play that serious maybe
like it was weird yeah no he made me
turn it off
so Amy did you turn it off before five
seconds
I don't think so no I think he thinks it
was playing longer than five seconds he
had nothing bad to happen do you see
what I'm saying we were playing it
earlier nothing bad has happened well
it's not over damn and we're roasting
you live on the show I just I don't want
you to live with this trauma Zach I
think we need to get you through this I
I you know I've acted legitimately
talked to my shrink about it really and
like what did he say about it she's like
she's she's like she's like yeah like
everyone has superstitions and I just I
just can't [__] with it I just can't it
just seems like it's enhanced it's
is causing an impediment on your life
like imagine you're on a date and then
she puts on oh that's happened and
you're like stop don't do that she's
like what she's gonna she's gonna leave
you she's gonna think you're such a
weirdo I was in a restaurant that
happened I'm like I I have to excuse
myself like I'm not even joking Zach you
cannot carry this around I I no [__]
my life up it [__] my life what if you
just say the name like 20 times oh you
just face it you know straight on we
have to test this like if we if you
if I say okay so what's the rules
because I say the name or it has to play
the music what are the rules tell me
everything is a problem just the even
the the mention of looking at the main
guy like I was on Twitter and something
popped up and I'm like [__] like but
nothing bad happened that day that's
what I mean well the day isn't over yet
yeah but back then you said a picture
pop-up the other guy and you closed it
that was today oh so your whole day's
been cursed with this guy and then
coincidentally there was an Ethan
Bradberry video where this all started
and he was playing a song from that
specific group yeah he sent it to us and
then I was watching and he's like wait I
just realized what's playing in the
background turn it off wait what do you
mean Ethan Bradberry started this it was
you know remember today he posted a
video and yeah
Bradbury's video was Cece well I
understand that but what do you mean
Ethan Bradberry started all this because
Zach's I want to hear from Zach okay he
started the conversation because I'm
like oh no no no turn that off turn that
off I I realized as I after I sent it
to
our chat that um there was a certain
song playing okay so your your phobia
existed before the Ethan Bradberry
incident but you said to this chat and
then you erased it from the chat no it's
still in the chat oh boy oh and but
nothing's bad happened since you sent it
in the chat you understand what I'm
saying No this is happening this is a
nightmare yeah but see this doesn't
count this doesn't count as something
bad we're just Victor here said I listen
to that I'm not gonna say it for you
thank you Ela thank you every time
before an exam so far I haven't flunked
once not cursed yeah I mean millions of
people every day listen to this band I I
understand I've blocked them from my
Spotify from my what mute like I I have
a donation Zach feels a Bad Moon Rising
oh you [__] oh
I already bought a lot of those puns
earlier
Zach this day's already ruined so I feel
like what does it matter if we saturate
it with more
I said what if you're fishing and
somebody goes boy that water looks clear
but that that's I mean that's how about
that clear water what about that
that's fine I guess just like the term
Credence would [__] me up Credence it's
the Credence that gets you it's just bad
[__] man it just you know you think I'm
crazy it's just bad [__] Jesus dear
parents you know about this yeah they do
how do you hide it from anybody well no
it's they're like okay you know you have
bad luck [__] you know like I just I
just can't [__] with it and I love
somebody Put a Spell on You dude what
and in The Big Lebowski if I recall it
correct me if I'm wrong doesn't he get
into a car accident while listening to
Credence in that movie uh yes sir yes he
does you just want to be Jeff Bridges
this is just no no no this started this
started this started wait wait wait
oh you just want to be the dude
everybody stop ordering the court plus
if I may say he doesn't like it actually
finding that I got that out yeah I mean
I've seen The Big Lebowski like a
billion times I never thought about that
but Zach
how is it that The Big Lebowski can be
your favorite movie if that song is so
cursed to you it's not my favorite movie
it's one of my favorite movies how is
that possible shouldn't you just not
watch that movie altogether if it's so
cursed no you skip the scenes dude
your favorite movie and at the same time
skip scenes
this is this is the hell I live in my
Joker brain stop with the joker brain oh
my God this is in Joker brain this is
just stop
stop this is odd bro I'm telling you you
guys think I'm crazy you know but this
is just straight facts and I I believe
you what else happened to you as a
result like speeding ticket not a big
deal there's just been also your fault
not ccrs
um true were you speeding Zach
just like were you speeding yes okay
well yeah
song came on
only circumstance just just weird [__]
happens okay tell me everything that's
happened you said you were in a car
crash and I want to know everything
that's happened and then let me draw a
conclusion if this song is cursed or not
there was like one instance when I was
in my college days and I was with my
buddy and we heard it in the car and he
ended up like slipping and falling like
immediately after and then the rest of
the day he got written up because we
were like was he Gravely injured or
something no no but it's just weird
minor [__] just [__] happens what
grade was this in uh he was in uh he was
a sophomore in college okay how do you
get written up in college what is that
well we were we were at a party at his
college and we were on the balcony
having beers and
the [__] ra like picked up on it and
it was just it just just all things that
could go wrong so let me get this
straight a song was playing he tripped
and fell he was not injured at all
well you know just a few scrapes and
[__] you know yeah later in the day you
got written up how do you attribute the
write-up to the song
because I feel like it wouldn't have
happened how do you make that connection
that's just like you're talk you're
talking about like 12 hours later whoa
Ela oh what the f
even moved the desktop but it's my
understanding that I got scared because
all the wires and [__] oh [__] that's
right it's it's something now because it
is sure yeah see what I [__] mean
nothing happened that that's just went
up
that I love I love how Zach's Vietnam
flashbacks are like I got a speeding
ticket and my friend got right my
friend's boyfriend tripped and he was
totally fine there's been you've seen
the table went up and nothing happened
there's a chance that wouldn't have
happened if we weren't talking about it
but nothing bad happened it's a shitty
curse it's not a boat and curse it's a
very info and curse something literally
all that happens okay what else happened
people want us to move on ah
my show my rules what else happened can
I read a few
people are saying
um wait where did they go
is that it Zach is there anything else
[Music]
it's just bad okay
okay what how much to get you in a room
and just blast that music soldiers all
streams CCR at the same time to release
Zach from this film oh we have to let go
that's cruel
why
just like everybody else do you approve
if everyone unhexes you in the chat no
I'm not gonna hear it he thinks he's
getting a super curse see now I hear one
of the songs in my head and I can't sing
it
no you'll release the card exactly you
gotta Purge what if we get crazy
everyone's over it over we'll get
claimed you have that much faith in your
singing really I thought it was funny
everybody wants to tell me how to run my
show
and the thing is people compare me to
the dude's voice all the time which
[__] my head up
how humble thank you
I don't want to be compared to Satan I
mean no don't vote any rules shut the
[__] up Dare You Devil he's the Devil
he's the Devil he's the devil God like
you're so weird about it well you're
losing it I mean it's I was I was
driving along and I just heard squealing
I looked to my left and there was a car
oh my God pretty much 90 degrees you
know on the freeway on the freeway let's
get out uh yeah so I thought it was a
blowout that was like my
in the in that moment I was like they
had a tire blow out and they're like
swerving to the side and there was a car
in my way on the other side of me
um kind of like in my blind spot so I
had to like swerve hard and speed up and
get out of there and I almost like
fishtailed uh getting out of there but I
managed somehow I managed to keep
control of the car was there a crack um
there was no crash but then I I like
slowed down I was like holy [__] I was
expecting the car that did that to also
slow down because I assume their tire
blew out
and instead they speed up and I see they
are like Road raging with another car
and they're like they're Chariot racing
they're like trying like they're
chickening like down the freeway like 70
miles an hour [__] [__] humanity
is done yeah humanity is over yeah this
[__] experiment is a failure Dan
doesn't want to admit the true reason
why I did that happen yesterday
go ahead well we he brought up uh
why are you going Zach you're doing it
to yourself but doing it to yourself
because I can bring it up with that
conversation
exactly that's why it happened every
single after we talked about it on the
show every single person in this office
experienced some type of bad luck you're
an idiot that is not true
Ian can vouch for me a b can vouch for
me
I will say I have some bad luck I was
miraculously avoided
the thing every time clearance
Clearwater plays a song on the radio
it's true you guys don't want to [__]
believe me
the crazy thing is people think you're
kidding but you're not I'm my hand of
[__] God
like no sympathy because this is what
happened we were talking about what
happened so were you listening to uh
Clarence Clarence no
so why are we talking because Dan Dan
brought the name up yesterday I mean
they brought the name he brought it up
man he [__] brought it up and and
this [__] happens now thank God we're
okay Dan it happened and it happened
yesterday morning no no the day before
we were talking about that how long does
the curse last if someone mentions it
you have 24 to 48 hours that's the curse
window dude nothing happens to me but
you could have been happening I'm just
I'm just saying in this case it was good
luck I I didn't I disagree
CCR John fogler was in heaven looking
down upon me and I know he's not dead
but he's still the [__] future he's
looking down on the [__] fact you're
in that predicament though don't you
think there's some I dare I say Credence
to it
[Laughter]
no
what excuse me
slain
continue
for him why is there an LP there that's
the scariest thing
you guys are [__] man
[Music]
long ago
this is summer
um
where's Sam
he's right there
[Music]
guys guys you're not gonna like what I
just got on this it just said Jewish
people
I swear to God it just said Jewish
I love you
I'm not kidding no you're the one that
led me here you walked me in this wall
you literally walked me I feel like I'm
in a psych ward right now I thought I
saw something
let's move on let's get out y'all make
me feel like I'm at Shutter Island right
now someone told me long ago okay
um pretty simple I guess but probably a
deeper meaning as to why I'm scared of
it
um Birds
yep so that explains why you were
freaking out over the geese well it's
it's not like I was freaking out over
the geese I was freaking out over their
[__] no but you had like an irrational
hatred for geese bro I think it's just
like all birds in general okay that's
interesting so what's wrong what
happened with birds I don't know but um
when I was younger like between four
through eight I was in occupational
therapy because what I mean my motor
skills really weren't like advancing
with my age when you say motor skills
does that mean like talking walking yeah
like I would I couldn't like grab a ball
properly I couldn't that's interesting
because you're so you're such a talented
guitar player right it takes so much
manual dexterity it's yeah interesting
that you were under yeah underdeveloped
with that yeah so I maybe that helped it
I don't I don't know but um
I would I was just I was an occupational
therapy and I worked with this this
woman
for many years and she became family and
she helped me try and get over my fears
and do things and one of them was Birds
but we tried going to a bird
Park bird sanctuary and um
I couldn't do it I freaked out wow so
what would so paint the picture for me
you're at a bird sanctuary yeah is it
one of these things where it's like a
big open-air cage yeah yeah yeah okay so
how far into the sanctuary did you get I
couldn't go through the door like I
can't go through the door did you start
crying and freaking out yeah like did
you run away yeah yeah yeah it was awful
and I I can't even go to like the
farmer's market you know like the Grove
with all the pigeons and [__] I can't do
it I just really like what about
seagulls
if I'm away from them at the beach and
that's fine but like if they're coming
up to me with like food when you're on
the beach I'm like nah gotta go sorry
and what's the scariest bird in your
opinion
[__] Crow or pigeon like I know it's
the pigeon is really not that
intimidating if you look at it in
retrospect but I just hate the
fluttering and like my worst nightmares
having like a bird on my head really
it's not so much of pecking at me it's
just like fluttering and [__] what is it
about the birds that uh is are you
repulsed are you scared I I don't know
what it is I um I don't know last
Christmas we had a Secret Santa
in which Ian
gifted a cursed Cosby doll and we've
been secretly tracking the whereabouts
of this cursed uh Cosby doll Zach recent
well I'll just play it I mean this thing
is Switched hands this curse has been
transferred so many times starting with
by the way Dan leaving it in the [__]
basement
and I was like Dan you can't leave this
[__] here he goes oh it doesn't fit in
my car I was like really [__] it
doesn't fit in your car you're gonna
leave that here so it's changed hands so
many times and it's all been documented
so I'd like to present you guys today
the path of the cursed Cosby doll
oh my God
I'm a cosmic kid oh no she's gonna put
it back it's cursed this thing is so
cursed bro this was described to me as a
haunted baby cradle
bring that into my [__] house
survived a fire in 1930. what the seller
described it as oh my God really
shouldn't have brought that into my
house
disrespected the [__] out of you guys
today he double parked he brought you
out
you really brought this into my [__]
house at least you gave it to Dan and
not me
[Music]
all right Zach wants a chair she's gonna
get the chair
I think I mean thanks for bringing it up
what the [__] is this it's the chair bro
it's all you baby is your [__] ass no
no I didn't put my ass on it
all right
it's it's a fair deal bro I brought the
chair you take the
dog's gonna roll down the stairs that is
so uncool
I bring the chair and leave the [__]
doll I gotta Burns here [__] safe I'm
doing bad voodoo in here man
[__] I'm just standing up here [__] off
dude
Zach
Vibes into a house oh so you brought the
sage out to give to do like a voodoo
curse release on the to Cleansing yeah
okay okay do you do a lot of cleansing
rituals
this is the toilet every morning
go give to the neighbors I'm not hauling
that [__] back I don't want the [__]
chair we'll put you up as you guys see
you see I can't there's no winning I got
the sage burning this is [__]
you're mixing yeah
why would you do this why why I thought
he's doing a bit but he really doesn't
want to take the chair bro there it was
haunted oh Zach you're definitely all
right you're tempting fate right there
I really thought he was doing a bit he
doesn't want to take it you guys are
[__] up all right
you have something drink dude I just
broke my face I'm dying the [__] out of
here you'll be good man
did you take the chair Zach
yeah he's sitting there right now
comfortable as you love to care oh my
God okay good after everything I'm glad
you at least enjoyed okay with all that
being said however there's still parts
to Zach that we're not covered basically
he's just a legend he's an iconic guy
and he has so many great moments these
are just the ones that are left over
that need to be talked about Zach tell
your uh P Diddy Story please we got a
story
if you want to look at Zach's car what
is this yeah exactly have a P Diddy star
what's going on Zach
so I was telling Ian
um oh my right my my foreskin
from my bris is in P Diddy's backyard
okay let me take that in for a moment
so
okay hold on let me you want me to
explain or do you want to think about it
okay so let me let me ask some questions
here why where were you okay yeah let's
start with what let's let's start with
why okay so before P Diddy owned the
house my grandfather owned the house and
I had my breasts there Circa 1997. you
just throw it in the garden
no they bury it like there's some Jewish
I mean it's almost barbaric you know in
a way but you know it's cleaner
um but we're discussing we're not here
to discuss the marathon circumcision
so when I was circumcised they buried it
in the backyard my grandfather passed
away about 10 years ago the kid sold the
house he wasn't my blood grandfather but
my grandmother was married to him and
who I referred to as my grandfather
so it was this house and you know when
he passed away the kid sold the house
and
um P Diddy bought the house and so my
Forest vis-a-vis
P Diddy's backyard and funny enough his
son was in my graduating class okay uh
and there was one time where because the
kid was kind of a dick like I'm not
gonna really if he didn't raise him
right up we got into it I got my P Diddy
in your yard [__] got him
um and
um I'm like yeah well my [__]
foreskin's in your backyard oh my gosh
that's just like a weird statement like
maybe like you're weird you could never
imagine that was true yeah so my
foreskin's in his backyard
hmm I'd like it back oh this is it yeah
so P Diddy lives here
I had my childhood in this home
I want my foreskin back oh Jesus
rest in peace Biggie Smalls we love them
too
yep let's find some more celebs to her
ass
you think we got any police calls for
today that'd be kind of exciting last
episode we did it was a it was Dripping
oozing and drama and controversy because
Zach
was upset that a b got the chair
that Razer gave us
now I will say that there's an update
there's a little bit of a resolution a b
decided that the chair does not fit in
his apartment it's too big for his
apartment and so he handed it down to
Zach oh that's very it's very kind of
you're welcome
wow very kind of him
uh very kind of you Ethan anyway uh to
even offer you know buying me a new
chair which was you know totally
unnecessary but um Zach you seen a
little down the comments were very
brutal on you I'll say they were great
they beat the [__] out of me
there was a hashtag fire Zach
maybe one person
they really beat the [__] I don't know
yeah they weren't happy with Zach they
thought he was throwing a hissy fit
well Zach let me ask you this I just I
mean not not to stir the pot but um do
you of course do you think you can
delete it and take a look I'm look
taking a look I'm giving it a smell I
mean a b gave it to you because he
didn't because it didn't fit his
apartment is that really gracious of him
I mean you know it's like dropping it
off at a junkyard right so I mean I'll
take it you know did you already get it
or not yet no I I still have to go pick
it up there's no winning there's no
winning he's gonna you gotta go pick it
up
should [__] bring it to me I'm
[__] around Mister Mister Hot Tub
over here
I gotta drop it off now too yeah you
gotta drop it you get a request too oh
ela's coming out I would like to demand
that a b himself
uh delivers it really
I had a very interesting
um
observation because I was the one
handing the chairs and so I noticed that
Lena picked it up for a b right Sam
picked it up
I thought it was 4 Ian but I guess it
was for Sam yeah but it is interesting
it is interesting go ahead that we got
girl power here so the ladies to pick up
the huge heavy objects on behalf of the
guys interesting thoughts talk to me
baby
even Ela I don't know I can't I can't
argue no more even Elis turned her back
on me I mean well because look at you
you're a Mr hot tub with your shade okay
can you show your shirt can you show
your shirt you're as fake as that
leather jacket you're wearing bro you
want to show your shirt you want to show
your shirt show your shirt Amy sure
you're sure this is called embracing the
meme
it says clout Goblin Zachy I'm sure
having a good time having some brisket
yeah I requested like I said no turkey
this year yeah I'm like I want a big ass
[__] rib eye steak and I'm getting it
damn who's buying it uh family my I'm
going down to my grandmother's and
you're like Grandma I need a big ass rib
eye I'm like I'm 24. I've done enough
[__] thanksgivings I want steak so is
anyone else eating turkey yeah my whole
my whole family and you just said
Grandma you need to buy my ass to stay
yeah Jesus a little bit of a prima donna
a little bit I mean it will what do you
have your own table like in the corner
it's the cool kids table yeah cool kids
table so you're gonna be the only guy at
this place eating a steak Yeah and
everyone else is eating turkey yeah nice
I'm looking forward to the price uh a
little minute yeah Easy Bake Oven
actually are you allowed to eat any of
the other Thanksgiving food I mean I
guess if I want I don't I would I would
prohibit it if I was your grandma I'd be
like listen [__] you want the steak
you can't have anything that Fitters or
anything else she knows I hate turkey so
I mean she was very accommodating about
it oh you hate turkey I do [__] hate
turkey
by the way lots of people were missing
you on um
Friday's act uh I Wish I Was Here uh I
chimed in and out of this oh my God you
didn't get the steak you were so [__]
confident you were gonna get the steak
and you didn't get the steak I got I got
[__] pretty hard I feel like I could
have predicted you weren't getting that
steak I was I was pretty set in stone I
was gonna get yeah [__] steak this
was this is a true reaction this is
absolutely cracked me up so Chantal was
like sitting next to me and she snuck
this photo and like I I was [__]
bummed as [__] dude so what did you tell
your nana when you're when she's like no
steak little [__] so the story was I
called her and this was like a week
before Thanksgiving and I'm like okay
you know I've been asking are you're
gonna you're gonna get this rib eye for
me right she's like yeah of course I'm
gonna go to the store I'm gonna get him
like all right you know all good I'll
jovial and
[__] show up and she's like all right
time to cook dinner
and she's like
ah shoot
I forgot the steak
you gotta bring your own steak bro she
didn't forget yeah she's like this kid
she's like the balls on this [__] kid
I'm spending all day cooking this turkey
and he's the only little snowflake that
got to come in with the special request
because I I and I I exclaimed to her
I've been eating [__] turkey for 24.
bring your own steak for 15 years 24. do
you understand that's not a lot of years
in in my time frame it is I've eaten
[__] dry ass [__] [__] turkey
whatever you're not you're you're 24
you're not like 80 like I'm 80. yeah
I've been hurt in Turkey for 80 [__]
years [__] turkey making me feel like
I'm you don't get to do that when you're
24. yeah how old's your grandma 82.
guess how long she's been eating turkey
82 years exactly but I I I was I was
bummed man like I was [__] I wasn't
pissed I was more sad like I I felt
really Bamboozled on that one you look
very sad I was so [__] yeah you do
look absolutely heart-wrenched and then
I had to eat [__] dry the sides were
good dude it's such like it's like for
you to sit at the table with everyone
and eat a steak it feels to me like a
bit of like I'm the man of the house
kind of thing it's king [__] dude but
you're not the king of your [__]
family's Thanksgiving dinner in my head
I am right okay that's why she didn't
buy it for you yeah she I think I think
she knew what she was doing she
definitely put you in your place a
little bit I think she knew what she was
doing
um but I got [__] pretty hard dude it
was it was bad yes
are they specific faces what is going on
Alfredo no no no
[Laughter]
okay that's not bad now we got my
[__] steak we got Zach his
Thanksgiving steak when did you make
that though Thanksgiving oh my God
are you serious no no no it hasn't been
sitting there since awesome teach we got
him now douche literature and and the
Stanley Tucci cookbook
thank you wait Can he eat that steak
because everybody go that steak is ready
one more thing what is this
this is the fork and knife oh utensils
yeah we thought of everything wow
where's the twist yeah what's the
[__] twist we thought it's kind of an
anti-twist oh
steak or something what's up with the
case the case is a little sketchy and
might stink a little if you get a good
wish show the case please the front of
it it looks crazy are you gonna eat that
food here Jack no wait the steak come on
this is your Thanksgiving stickers I
feel like look at Sam she just cooked
this look at her sandwich
[Laughter]
I don't want anything that's like is it
no tell me what's up with the case if
that case kept it warm
I feel like there's some dark [__] with
that man what do you think it transfers
the food yeah kind of yeah it was
keeping it warm and secure I don't want
it
do they all have that you've won a
redeem at feastable.me wait what yeah it
says I want something absolutely
I mean it's not a golden ticket but I
want something oh mine doesn't have one
I was gonna say they all I think there's
lots of prizes probably one one per box
or something wait I'm gonna put in the
code so don't show the screen for a
second
what did we win
you can show now all right
oh
Ethan congratulations my friend you
didn't win [__] [__]
[__] loser
take it from me you just got zilly zonka
congratulations you were one of [__]
factors of rotten fruit with fruit flies
and worms and you see that chocolate
fountain that's not chocolate that's my
[__] he's certainly drinking my [__]
Augustus Ethan
you're a [__] loser
you no way you just got [__] silly
stuff
[Music]
I thought this chocolate bar was already
open I was like this [__]
yo but what's that that's real though
ticket you guys got
we made it very elaborate we went
through a lot of effort for this um this
is a fake ticket let's see it says go to
urlpadpoint.me
to redeem and use code nft Expo pad I
guess I'll do that right now I don't
want I don't want anyone to beat me to
it right Ian here we go it's exciting
thank you Ian by the way I appreciate
getting on the ground floor of this yeah
across the website it's a fantastic
opportunity I think well you know oh
look it loaded oh go ahead
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you for me one of the founders of
this [__] [__]
just got effort into a on Saturday
[Music]
I'm gonna [__] your mom
why don't you wipe my pad
you're a [__] idiot
okay
[Music]
well thank you guys I hope you all
enjoyed our first comprehensive lore
video on Zach there'll be more coming
for each crew member and topics we'll
keep them coming but we're going to take
our time and make sure they're all great
I want to thank the crew for helping to
put this Juggernaut together Dan
spearheaded it thank you to Dan and I
want to thank this user on the subreddit
Waddles Jr who put together this
incredibly comprehensive list of lore
that that was helpful to us putting this
video together so thank you to M and uh
thanks for watching guys we'll see in
the next lore video
[Music]